but then again it's c plus plus so i
don't know what their fascination with
operator overloading is
but the whole way that like now if you
want to concatenate
like file system paths using the file
system api you just
use the forward slash like divided by
operator
to just add parts together and i'm like
i thought that was a joke when i saw
that like on
some code but i don't know they just
love their operators
maybe it's like oh look i'm
i'm typing a path well no no it makes
sense
it makes sense but it's just a little
odd to see that like in the code i guess
um it's quite funny though i think yeah
it's
like i i saw
the guy who was that was the chili maybe
chili
um i don't know if if you watched him
or do you know who chili's uh chili
tomato noodle
of his um um yeah he's
funny in his awesome and um
one of his videos he shows the vector
like arithmetic vector and
he he goes like okay so we have addition
it's plus okay the
subtraction is minus um that and that
and cross product hmm which operator
would i use oh percent
it looks like a little cross makes sense
yeah it makes sense
so well that's what when you see it like
one vector percent another vector
what's going on
that's right so
yeah it operators
you can go crazy with them
yeah that was you can easily go crazy
with them
oh there was some
i don't remember what this was
unfortunately i don't know maybe this
was a boost
thing but there was like some
serialization library
and i think they used the ampersand well
wasn't it it was like
it was like a bit wise and the bit wise
and i guess operator because it's not
like a reference thing in between two
things to put objects into a stream or
whatever
yeah i think they also use
uh some other operator maybe in
this pipe thing yeah like war um
well and again uh streams uh input
streams they use the
left shift and right shift yeah to you
know
write and read but that makes sense
really
because you are left shifting something
into a c out
probably you want to push it pushing it
you're
that's how i see it but that was
interesting because
um when that was one of the weird things
when i was coming from java
into cbos plus obviously the first thing
you learn about is how do i print
hello world to the console and it's like
oh
and i and then i was like because i was
doing like software rendering
algorithms and stuff in java so i was
very much aware of like the bit
operators
and i was like why why is is this what
is this
how is this bit shift left like i
literally spent like
hours i think being like is this some
kind of weird mathematical thing that
i'm not getting
like how is the string
being bit shifted into the output stream
oh that was good times ah that's that's
so cryptic that
that's the thing like you c plus plus
hello world
and you're already like what is
happening with
with this why can't i just do
system.out.printline or
console.writeline in c
sharp it's so simple and then c plus is
like well you need to
you know shift this left into this place
yeah it can be it can be difficult
uh when you see it for the first time it
will put you off cars
right yeah that's that's i feel like
that's almost a fair introduction into
staples class and just how flexible and
crazy it is